pour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ces
enfants
mes amis c'est à nous maintenant août
stable j'avais de grands shows de
grandes idées mais moi j'ai une énorme
aider avec les plombs vous connaissez
calloway que les calloway vie comme un
reclus personne l'a vu depuis quinze ans
je vous donne trois semaines pour me
présenter un show parfaitement menée je
ne vous décevrai pas monsieur et
vaudrait mieux sinon je vous balance du
toit
j'ai toujours rêvé de me produire avec
sursis titre je suis tout petit
nos limites ici on ne t'a
rez-de-chaussée qui pas de jambes et
idées à traquer la vie commune ce triste
adieu les pointures les pointes je ne
vois pas de réponse du tout voici ma
fille porsche à elles vont rencontrer
calloway elle est fan mon assistante est
en route pour le rencontrer en ce moment
même
[Musique]
votre destination sur votre droite sur
ma droite ça marche
si tu pouvais me donner des leçons dans
itunes sauverait la vie comment je peux
savoir que t'es pas un type scholly
comment je peux savoir c'était rigolo
[Musique]
non
je savais que tu étais chelou musique et
16 des 19 fait et maintenant la star de
notre spectacle
rosita
je peux essayer non non non
on heures elle serait jamais capable de
jouer ce personnage c'est peut-être lieu
je vais écrire un autre rôle rosita
voit la clé calloway allez vous aime la
musique ne vous manque pas vous n'avez
qu'à recommencer à jouer non je ne peux
pas je n'ai plus entendu seul de mes
chansons depuis plus de 15 ans et pour
une très bonne raison
quoi
alimenter
iver
[Musique]
les
chansons nouveaux core tier 1
chanter
il est plus d'une seule issue pour toi
très demandé
fait de grand et magnifique raid
c'est ce que j'ai toujours dit non
voilà
on a toujours le choix c'est juste que
j'ai jamais eu le courage de faire le
monde
gunther en mode piqué paroisse